I have a godson too I got you beat yeah  it's a competition always how many  parents do you have to love each other  uh  one  how many players one they love  themselves yeah I think why would I like  that one I'm trying to go like I'm in  Vegas now I'm trying to make everything  Vegas now so far it's Nikki said because  my folks are dealing with my grandma's  situation but oh I didn't see you my  grandma's about to die oh okay you're  updated bam I don't like I can't see  your eyes for these moments  you just look like a Pit Boss I don't  even know who he's looking at right it's  funny because [ __ ] Anthony started  the day off like hey guys we got a real  wholesome